welcome to the smite guard reveal for
Silla horror of the deal
if you believe that pure evil exists
scholars claim evil is nothing more than
an opposing moral viewpoint they are
wrong evil exists and she waits just
beneath the surface of the sea Scylla
they call her horror of the deep no ship
that dares sail in her waters goes
unscathed those that cling to survival
whisper panicked tales of enormous black
tentacles tipped with slobbering hound
heads ravaging whole ships to splinters
with pitiless precision though it's her
laughter they say that's most horrible
childlike delighting in blood-soaked
murder as men are dragged into the dark
abyss poets have tried to romanticize
this beast to provide some humanity to
her monstrosity they write she was once
a beautiful nayad wronged by a jealous
priestess and transformed in truth she
was born this way baguette by God's full
of jealousy and loathing dropped into
the sea to terrorize mankind would that
she had remained in the sea that evil
has come ashore dragged by dog-headed
tentacles she roams our streets Flux us
from our beds and fills the night with
disturbing laughter Scylla has come and
not even the gods can help us
zyliss passive is called quick learner
each of sylla's abilities gain an
additional effect at maximum rank Scylla
also gains additional magical power for
each max rank ability her first ability
is called cecum Scylla sends two hounds
forward damaging routing and crippling
the first enemy hit at max rank two
additional enemies nearby the first
target will also be hit her second
ability is called crush Scylla creates a
magical field that slows enemies after a
short duration it detonates and causes
damage Scylla can activate the ability
to detonate it early at max rank enemies
in the area also have their magical
protection reduced and are slowed
sylla's third ability is called Sentinel
Scylla summons her sentinel Zoe to the
target area granting her ward vision for
a short duration Scylla may activate the
ability again to move to Zoey's target
location when this ability is not on
cooldown Scylla gains mp5 sylla's
ultimate is called I'm a monster Scylla
reveals her true nature becoming CC
immune and gaining movement speed she
may make one powerful attack during this
time if she kills an enemy god with the
attack she may attack again at max rank
the movement speed bonus doubles
in this first scenario Silla attempts to
flee from Shanga and soba quit Sentinel
turning around Silla gets caught by
anubis's mummify as he casts plague of
locusts retaliating with cecum and crush
Silla dodges anubis's death gaze long
enough to take him down with a few basic
attacks in this second scenario Silla
takes down Poseidon with I'm a monster
shifting towards left lane to aid her
allied gab she strikes down as Cupid
flees closing the distance with Sentinel
Scylla misses with cecum as a final
crush takes down the god of love in this
final scenario Silla enters a teamfight
in mid lane initiating with a crush
sentinel and cecum combo she helps take
down the enemy Shanga activating
sentinel Silla moves to Arachne as a few
basic attacks take down the Weaver
moments later Silla follows mercury into
battle against Sobek teleporting with
Sentinel Silla connects with cecum and
crush as the god of the Nile attempts to
flee a final blow with I'm a monster
gets the kill
as the horror of the deep Silla malls
down all who dare oppose her starting
her off with crush can aid Scylla
clearly early game minion waves as well
as slow down enemies next picking up
cecum can help still a further lockdown
enemies aiding her allies as well as
helping her secure the kill from there
the priorities shift to I'm a monster
crush cecum Sentinel
moonbots Selanne's on the battleground
with the brand new space monkey skin
thanks for watching the smite god reveal
for Silla horror of the deep